certains le surnomment le syndrome de la
havane
le résultat d'une mystérieuse attaque
dite acoustique qui aurait eu lieu entre
les murs des résidences diplomatiques
canadiennes et américaines
moi je souvenu d'avoir entendu chez
chaud venant du fond du jardin
un bruit d'une machine métallique de
retour au pays
ces diplomates canadiens parle pour la
première fois sous couvert de l'anonymat
il s'entoure beaucoup match on sent que
lulu contre on touche au coup de latte
août à la même période une de ses
collègues éprouvent des symptômes
similaires
[Musique]
chaque diplomate a son histoire
c'est l'incompréhension totale cette
diplomate de carrière qui a vécu dans
des zones dangereuses ne comprend pas ce
qui lui arrive elle et à ses filles
il faut croire qu'un faux pas même lui
duchamp pas tout pendant des mois ils
n'en parlent pas la consigne était
claire aux états unis la faire éclater
au grand jour
monsieur taxe promet 24 diplomates
américains sont évacués d'urgence
il souffre de lésions cérébrales
traumatiques légère de ce qu'offre
tracks la sphère est ouvertement
débattue par un comité sénatorial
présidée par le sénateur marco rubio
tournée au canada l'histoire ne fait pas
grand bruit
même si un médecin a été dépêchée sur
les lieux à la havane si diplomate
affirme aujourd'hui avoir été laissés à
eux mêmes ils vont tous les spécialistes
pendant six mois je n'avais aucune idée
de qualité mondiale au stick finale gsm
edge est bien normal même si l'autre
spécialiste de la défense habituelle
mais bon mon fils
désespéré certains d'entre eux se
rendent par leurs propres moyens à
l'université de pennsylvanie
l'objectif être évalués par les mêmes
experts que les américains nous sommes
allés à la prestigieuse école de
médecine des diplomates ont été
examinées le docteur dog le smi est une
sommité sur les questions qui touchent
les commotions cérébrales
l'équipe médicale est perplexe
le docteur dog le symev part d'un
syndrome ou le cerveau était visé sound
qui tenait alors que son dossier médical
étaient fermées par la défense
canadienne cette diplomate suit un
protocole médical car elle apprend que
son cerveau a été touché
je n'ai pas mais c'est mon rôle de
support aujourd'hui si ces diplomates
parlent publiquement c'est à contrecoeur
une chose en plus en parlant qu'il me
rende compte professionnel mais il
s'agit de leur santé et celle de leur
famille tout dire que la châtenois paso
doble base de beaucoup louent ne devrait
pas c'est d'abord pour mon ministère
j'ai de l'espoir de retrouver sa
jeunesse et sport donc trouver l'argent
dj cinéma
pour le dr us met les etats unis doivent
se préparer à des attaques similaires
dans l'avenir sauf que pour le moment le
mystère demeure entier autour de cette
histoire qui est à l'origine de cette
présumée attaque et pourquoi
ouais vraiment étrange à z alors quels
sont les derniers développements alors
vous l'avez dit au début ça cuba ça va
être un poste non accompagnés alors
juste pour vous donner une idée
ce sera le même statut que tripoli et
kaboul en afghanistan donc des zones à
risques alors cfm il a évidemment
autrefois cuba était considéré comme
l'endroit idéal pour un diplomate c'est
un endroit très sécuritaire le canada et
cuba entretiennent d'excellentes
relations
alors aujourd'hui ce cas faire mondiale
annoncée c'est que il rapatrie les
familles qui sont en poste là bas les
familles des diplomates également les
familles qui devaient être postés à cuba
cet été reviendront ils ont également
réitéré que leurs relations avec cuba
demeurent excellentes constructive et
que les autorités cubaines collabore
avec les autorités canadiennes sur cette
affaire très mystérieuse ouais mais la
question demeure qui peut bien être à
l'origine de tout ça si ces lignes c'est
la grande question d'ailleurs elle a été
posée au comité sénatorial alors aux
états unis marc rubio a dit écoutez tout
ce qui se passe à cuba les autorités
cubaines sont au courant donc si ce
n'est pas cuba
ce serait un tiers pays un sénateur a
posé la question est ce que ce serait
les russes alors toutes les hypothèses
sont bonnes pour le moment on sait pas
vraiment qui est à l'origine de cette de
cette attaque
la grc et le fbi enquête et puis dans le
monde médical on se pose des questions
on vient de le voir on s'est dit il
faudra se préparer ça veut dire qu'il ya
une arme qui circulent on ne sait pas
laquelle et qui arrive à donner une
commotion à des personnes qui n'ont eu
aucun impact sur la tête donc c'est
vraiment une affaire mystérieuse
mystérieuse et inquiétante merci à z
[Musique]